a question like this can be perplexing
to solve because when you look at it the
first time
you might be tempted to think where do i
even begin
to start with a question like this i'm
going to show you two approaches for
solving this one that i think is
the most elegant and i would think
especially because this is a multiple
choice question
uh probably the best way to go um it's
going to rely on a lot of visual and
geometric thinking which you might have
seen is a theme throughout complex
numbers
and then i'm going to show you a second
approach which is
you might think a little more you know
algebraic and for those of you who
look at this and can't get to that
visual intuition um that might be a
better way to go but it is
very long and i'm going to try and make
an argument for why even though it will
arrive
at the right solution why i wouldn't um
use it as uh
as my approach if i could help it at all
so let's have a go
at reading this together what's the
maximum value of
the modulus of e to the i theta minus 2
plus the modulus of e to the i theta
plus two
for uh this range for theta from naught
to two pi all right what's what's going
on here now in order to start tackling
this question
um you know it can be overwhelming just
looking at this weirdo looking
expression
up here you're like where do i even
start with this what does it even mean
what does it look like so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to
sort of look at a classic mathematics
problem-solving strategy which is when
you get you know
you encounter a complicated object and
you get confused by it
what you do is use you know sort of
consider a simpler version
of this problem and then try and like
gain insight from that and then build on
those insights until you get to the
problem that you're actually looking at
so let's consider um you know and in
fact i'm even going to write
that consider a much simpler version of
the problem
um you can see this is about maximizing
a
moduli of some kind so part of the you
know fact that it's confusing is that
there are two different moduli that have
been added together
and then there's all this weird
complicated stuff inside each of the
individual
modulis so let's consider something much
much simpler
just a single modulus and
you can see that there's this minus two
plus two business we'll come to that in
a second
let's just think about what this means
what is the modulus of e
to the i theta well written in uh
exponential form e to the i theta is a
particular kind of complex number
remember that you know a complex number
can be written very generally in
rectangular form
a plus i b just go horizontally
somewhere go vertically somewhere
we can also write it in polar form with
the trigonometric
functions we can write it as r outside
of cos theta plus i
sine theta and then we went from this
polar form
noting that we can write using euler's
formula we can write this
as e to the i theta and then you've just
got this
modulus sort of hanging out the front
there right now what you can see
when you have a look at this the modulus
of this particular complex number as it
moves around
the thing about this is that there's no
r or r doesn't appear
and the reason for that is because r is
implied r of course in this case is
equal to 1
1 lot of e to the i theta so this is not
just
any set of complex numbers it is the set
of complex numbers
such that the modulus they've all got to
be equal to one
and being that the modulus is the
distance from the origin
these numbers are all on the
circumference of the unit circle
so let's just really briefly think about
what that looks like right
if you were to draw the unit circle
let's just pop it in there
that looks better okay so e to the i
theta
it can be anywhere on the circumference
of the circle it might be here
for some particular value of theta it
might be over here it could be down here
so long as you have this modulus of
one all of these points
satisfy um this you know e to the i
theta so they could all be
uh different values for this complex
number now the thing about this
is that asking for the modulus of all of
these different points because they're
all on the unit circle
by definition they're all the same
distance from the origin so that means
that the
modulus in question here is equal to 1
because the distance from the origin is
always going to be that radius right
so if we were to say hey what is the
maximum value
of this expression here this is a bit of
a silly question to ask because
the maximum value of something like this
well that
thing is constant right um the modulus
wherever you are
no matter what value of theta you choose
whether it's something like i don't know
what does that look like
pi on three this would be pi i have no
idea what that would look like but
you'd wind around no matter which theta
you choose your modulus here the modulus
of e to the i theta
is going to be one so the maximum value
i guess would be
one there's no maximum no minimum in
terms of changing
it doesn't vary right but then you
notice okay well i actually need to go
further than that right
i need to say well in addition to having
you know edi theta in there i've got edi
theta
minus 2. what does that mean this is not
the set of complex numbers on the unit
circle
how does this differ the answer is if we
then think about
you know what about
e d i theta and well let's have a look
at the minus two
version first minus two and then we take
the modulus right what does this mean
if i take uh let's actually go for some
examples now right um
this this one here this e to the i theta
that i i gave as an example i said that
looks like
pi on 3 to me if i were to look at that
angle of rotation so if i call that e
to the i pi on 3. i can write that
in rectangular form by saying what's cos
of pi on 3
that's going to be a half and
what is i sine
pi on 3 that's going to be i times root
3
on 2. so that would be the coordinates
of this particular point for this
particular value but now i'm considering
e to the i theta
minus 2. so in this context if i said
you know let's stay with purple if theta
is equal to
pi on 3 then e to the i theta minus
2 would be e to the i pi on 3
minus two equals let's think about this
right um i had
e to the i pi on three i i had it right
up here right so i can just
take this just grab that over here and
then as the uh
as the expression says i will subtract
2. so that's going to give me
a negative one and a half or negative i
should
maybe i'll write it in improper fraction
because i have this root 3 and 2 over
here as well
plus root 3 onto i so you can see
that -2 it has taken me over to the
negative direction
in the negative real direction i should
say so to the left right
now i would then say well what is the
modulus of this point
if i want the modulus of this right i'm
taking this whole thing
and so what i'm trying to do is now say
wait a second these points aren't on the
unit circle anymore
they've all been taken from the unit
circle and moved to the left
so what i can do is i can sort of employ
the same logic i can say all right i'm
still going to have
um a circle of radius one
but it's been moved over here uh to the
left
you can see it's sort of everything is
shifted over i used to have
this these real intercepts at 1 and
negative
1 when i subtract 2 from each of those
i'm going to get negative 1 and negative
3 in fact i might even write that down
negative 1 negative 3. now this point
here
that i've just identified right where
where is that
well 3 on 2 if this is
if this is negative 1 i guess that makes
my center here
negative 2 so negative 3 on 2
is going to be i'll place it about here
right
that's where that's going to be and you
can see because my scale is like
reasonably okay
if you have a look this is going to be
my
plus root 3 onto i that's me going in
the vertical
direction so this is where my point is
and to take the modulus
of that i then have to say well
what is this oops i meant to use this
what is this distance here the distance
to the origin and i just used pythagoras
wouldn't i
you can see that this here is root 3 on
two
and uh this distance here we've already
established is three
on two so then um to work this out i
would say
um let's call that well i'm working out
the modules here
that is let's put that arrow below here
that is the square root of and i'm just
going to do a squared plus b squared so
in this case
let's treat this as as a so a squared in
this case would be
3 over 4. and then over here i square
this as
well and that's going to be 9 over
4 and i don't know why i drew such a
long radical sign there we go
so i can simplify this a little bit this
is going to be
the square root of 12 over 4. so this is
root 3. so that's the distance there
right now you can see
as i change the value of theta i'm going
to be changing the position of this
point on the circumference of this
circle so if i were to have a theta
that was say bringing me my point on the
circumference down here
then the distance the modulus that i'm
after this modulus here
that distance would just be one and if i
went all the way to the opposite side of
the circle
then the modulus would be three from 0
all the way to negative 3. so if i was
trying to maximize
just this thing here it is fairly clear
from my diagram that i want to pick
the furthest point away from the origin
which is obviously on the opposite side
of the circle
so that's simple enough when you just
have a single modulus edi theta
minus two but in fact i don't just have
a single
modulus i have two of them put together
i've just been considering this
and now i have to consider this as well
and now you can see why this is now an
interesting question right this is a
circle and it's been moved two units to
the left
this is going to be a similar circle
also radius one but it's been moved two
units to the right
and so it's going to be over i draw it
over here and i'm going to have to
compare distances between these as they
balance
out because i'm adding these two modules
to moduli together
trying to maximize for the sum of those
two things
now to help you visualize what's going
on because i'm now starting to consider
more things and waving around my hands a
lot more
uh let's get some dynamic geometry to
help us here right
here are the two circles that i was
considering before they each have
a radius of one and you've got this left
hand one with the center
at negative 2 and the right hand one and
a
having a center of positive 2 right now
what am i considering here well i'm
considering different points on the
circumferences of these circles
so for example if i took a an angle of
0.7 so that's something
that's pretty close to pi on 4 then you
get this point on the circumference of
each of the circles
and now you want to consider well what
are the moduli to each of those points
so if you have a think back to my
drawings here right
this one here looks pretty close to what
i was getting so you can see that mod
just going over
to the the second quadrant up to the top
left so when i come back to this diagram
i can add in not only that modulus but
the modulus to the other point
as well and so now you can see if i want
to
say take that value of theta that's what
i've
t for theta over there and put it over
all the way
to the left hand side so this is a value
of
about pi is what i'm trying to get on to
but my finger is not accurate enough
um i think i might just be able to type
in i'm just putting 1.4 there we go okay
so have a look at this right what i've
done is i've successfully maximized the
red
modulus right it's now three but getting
the maximum
for that modulus has given me by the
looks of things the minimum
for the other modulus you can see on the
right hand side that blue modulus over
there
that's just equal to one so i've got the
maximum for one the minimum for the
other
and as i uh move uh my angle around you
can see
um that those two distances are going to
change and i'm looking for
where is the maximum for each of those
okay
now at this point i am now going to say
all right i can
sense that i'm either going to get the
maximum
either at you know one of these spots
here like at that that
end point as it were like i'm at the
furthest for one and the shortest for
the other
or i will get the maximum when i try and
balance these two out
where can i get each one to be sort of
you know in between you know this one
the red one's the longest and the blue
ones the shortest
if i go all the way back to theta equals
zero i reverse that relationship now the
red one is the shortest the blue one is
the longest
there's going to be a middle spot right
so if you have a think
i already know for example if i take
theta equals zero
let's go and consider this right if
let's write this down if theta equals
zero then uh the actual
expression that i'm trying to maximize
this here is going to be
i'm going to have the absolute value of
e to the
0 minus 2 plus a to the 0
plus 2. what's that going to be equal to
well you can see here it's going to be 1
take away 2
and then 1 plus 2 and this gives me the
two coordinates that i got before
right you can see that one of my circles
will be at negative one
and the other circle will be at three
and so this is let's come back to desmos
you can see this is the red one on the
left that's my distance to negative one
and then the blue one on the right
my distance to 3. so when i think about
what this is that's obviously going to
be 1
plus 3 that gives me a distance of 4. so
what happens when i vary this
what's the in between point i know if i
go all the way over to theta equals
pi even though i've changed the angle
you're getting the same
sum between the moduli right because
you've got not one plus three but
three plus one same deal so what's the
in between point between zero
an argument of zero and an argument of
pi like i've roughly got here
well it's going to be pi on 2 isn't it
let's try and uh
get that in there you can see it's going
to
take place around that in fact i think i
might even let's see if i can get this
in here pi
on um so you can see there i've gotten
rid of my slider but that's because i've
chosen this particular value
what will the sum of my red and my blue
moduli be in this case
well if i draw a very rough diagram over
the top of this in fact i'm just going
to grab this
let's uh let's crop in to get the
relevant part here
come over here just because this can
draw a way better diagram than i ever
could
all right let's let's go over the top of
this right i've got these two distances
but i see that there's this symmetry to
the diagram right the red and the blue
moduli um they clearly exist in two
congruent triangles
they're the hypotenuses of two
congregations have been flipped across
the imaginary axis so what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to consider one
side
i'm just going to consider this side
over here
and you can see the red length there is
the hypotenuse of this right angle
triangle
i know that this is 1 this is 2 so this
is the square root of
1 squared plus 2 squared that's the
square root of 5.
now what i can say is well i've got 2 of
them right i'm adding the red
and the blue so therefore this distance
when
theta is pi on two
um the the sum is going to be equal to
uh
i'll just say i'm just going to call it
m for modulus um it's going to be
root five times plus root five which is
um 2 root 5
and even though i don't know what root 5
is off the top of my head
i know this has to be bigger than what i
got over here
which is 4 because 2 root 5 that has to
be bigger than 2
root 4 right that makes sense and of
course
2 root 4 that is 2 times 2 which is
which is 4.
so i immediately even though i don't
know what the exact value of root 5 is
it's something like 2.23 or something
like that
i know it's going to be bigger so this
is clearly the maximum
size which you can see is going to be
option c
so that's how i think is the best way to
think about this i should point out
you know this took a long time because i
sort of built from this simpler version
of the problem
and i sort of scaffolded to get to i
didn't want to land you on this
animation and be like wait
where did this come from i wanted you to
see how i conceptually arrived to that
point from a simpler version of the
problem
up to a more complicated version